so as we get into the New Avengers
incursions what we're going to find here
is that this story is going to lead
directly into the 2015 summer event that
is to say the end of everything or
Marvel is coming out with battleworld
and they're coming out with this story
whereby most likely the entire Marvel
Universe it gets revamp and so what we
do is we start with this an incursion
stories that we're going to be picking
up with New Avengers issue number one
and what happens here is black panther
realizes there's an another earth that's
currently I guess outside or orbiting
our current version of earth-616 and so
while he's looking at this alongside
several others that are part of his clan
he realizes that there are some other
individuals who are coming down who are
arriving from this alternate earth onto
the main earth-616 and what this woman
does is she speaks a language to the
other men that she's with that we can't
understand and she summons a device from
them now black panther realizes that the
language this woman is speaking is high
sumerian and this is a language that has
not been spoken on earth since 2000 AD
and so either this race is a very very
old racist maybe returning to the planet
earth or they're from an alternate
reality whereby this language is still
spoken but the fact remains that black
panther approaches this woman and begins
talking to her and what she does is
identify herself as a woman named black
swan and she reveals to Black Panther
that she can in fact speak English and
so Black Panther asks her if this planet
orbiting the alternate earth or this
altered earth orbiting the main
earth-616 planet Earth is her doing if
she is the reason why this has happened
but what she says here is that know that
she is not the person that summon an
incursion and then a person cannot
simply summon an incursion they cannot
cause an incursion to happen that the
incursion simply just happened on their
own and she referenced as a person named
Rob oom allow now this is going to be
very important and the reason why is
because what we're going to find
course of this incursions discussion
over the next four videos is that where
boom allow is effectively going to be
the reason behind why all this has
happened and so what happens here is
that Black Swan asked like Panther if
she was here to destroy a world would he
stop her and he says yes he says he
would do a lot more than stop her and he
immediately begins the process of trying
to attack them but before he's actually
able to do anything she informs her
henchmen to kill everybody and so what
happens is they use their weapons to
immediately start unloading on a black
panther as well as the rest of his clan
now over the course of this black
panther and Anna's clan are injured in
such a way to where Panther is the only
survivor and the rest of his clan died
and so Black Panther for the most part
swears vengeance against Black Swan and
so what happens here is that as Black
Swan is speaking with one of her
henchmen she tells her henchmen as her
henchmen whether or not he's capable of
doing what needs to be done and he says
no and so she strikes him down and then
she kills him and black panther at the
same time because assaulting the rest of
her henchmen and effectively kills them
all leaving Black Swan the only person
left alive and so what happens here is
Black Swan uses this device to destroy
the alternate earth and this leaves
Black Swan left at the hands of being a
prisoner for a black panther which of
course he takes her into custody and
takes the device into custody as well
and it's at this point at the end of the
story that Black Panther calls together
the Illuminati for the purpose of trying
to figure out what's going on here now
stepping into issue number two and with
these issues going forward and what we
find here is that Reed Richards begins
interrogating Black Swan once the
Illuminati are called together and this
is when we actually learn about what's
going on with the incursions we learn
about what's what's taking place like
what's actually happening with regards
to these alternate Earth's and what
Black Swan tells Reed Richards is that
the Great destroyer demands a sacrifice
but the problem here is we don't know
and even now we don't know who were
Booma wall is and we don't know if he's
the Great destroyer if the two of them
are combined or if perhaps this is just
some kind of mythology that has been
spread among their people or among her
people before the end of the world but
what Reed
sir is why it is that she destroyed that
planet if that's the planet that she's
from and what she says is that that
planet is not her planet but that it was
a planet Earth and the whole basis
behind this is that as far as Reed
Richards is concerned it doesn't make
any sense for someone to destroy their
own world and of course again black swan
says that this was not her home that she
has no real home
she says that the wheel of destruction
that is to say the game is being played
of the various Earth's being destroyed
requires a sacrifice then that this
sacrifice for the most part requires
that individuals give up who they are
that they make decisions they would
never normally make that is to say they
have to stop being heroes and start
making decisions about destroying other
worlds and so Black Swan says that Reed
Richards has no real idea what's coming
here that he has no real understanding
of what's going to take place and so
what Reed Richards asks is that she does
explain to him this and she tells him
what it is it's coming and so what we do
is we swish to Reed Richards as he's
speaking with the Illuminati as he's
explaining to them what the incursions
are and what he says is that within the
within the Marvel landscape you have the
entire multiverse that is to say you
have the very beginning of the
multiverse you have the very end of the
multiverse and you have a infinite
number of Earth's within this entire
multiverse if a possibility exists then
a reality exists for it and he says that
it's somewhere along the line on an
alternate earth an event took place
there was some kind of destruction on
this alternate earth that resulted in
that earth being destroyed and so as a
result the entire life span that is to
say the time it would take for the
universe to end after its beginning has
been shortened but moreso than that this
explosion on this alternate earth caused
the two opposing earth to collide into
one another and because of that their
entire realities were destroyed and so
what he says is that the incursion is
basically the point in which an earth
first appears when the when I guess
people first become aware of this
alternate earth when we can physically
see it and so he says after this earth
appears there's exactly eight hours
before the two earths collide and at
this point they have two options either
they can do nothing and they can allow
both earth to collide and there you
versus the respective universes to be
destroyed entirely or they can destroy
one of the earths now if they choose to
destroy one of the earth it will only
destroy that earth and not the reality
as a whole the reality would keep on
existing it's simply that the the
reality would be devoid of that one
particular earth and so what happens
here is that the Illuminati begin towing
or I guess the very least discussing
even if only in an academic way what
would happen or the possibility of using
the device that belong to black swan' to
start destroying other worlds and
Captain America who of course again at
this point has taken over the role of
Charles Xavier and the Illuminati
immediately says no he says this cannot
be something that they do that instead
they have other powers at their disposal
namely the the Infinity Gauntlet
and so what dr. strange says is that
they will not be able to use the
Infinity Gauntlet the reason being
because they don't know where the mine
Jim John my Jemma is due to the fact
that Charles Xavier has been killed here
and so what name were the Samarin er
does is he speaks up and he says that
because the infinity gems communicate
with one another because they want to be
a whole he says that all they have to do
is use the other five gems and that will
tell them where the mine Jim is and so
what they do is they assemble the five
gems and they go about the process of
trying to find the location of the fifth
and fit or the six Infinity Jim the
actual mine Jim and so what we do here
is we pick up with beasts in New York
with the death of Charles Xavier and
what happens here is B so it's given an
envelope by the executor of Charles
Xavier zhis state now the executor says
this envelope has beyond the purview of
the executor meaning that the executor
doesn't know what's in this envelope and
so what happens is when beast opens this
envelope it's simply a piece of paper
with the words remember and what this
does is it triggers a long suppressed
memory in the mind of beast that had
been planted there by Charles Xavier and
what Charles Xavier does is he
effectively tells beast that within a
safe that he has hidden in his study or
I guess I a full colonel a chronology of
all the events that Charles Xavier had
been involved in as part of the
Illuminati but in addition to all this
information what we see is that within
the confines of this safe is also the
mine Jim and so when beast takes the
mind gem out the Illuminati immediately
become aware of its presence and they
tell where a teleport to where beast is
at and so what Captain America says is
that beasts is effectively being
inducted into the Illuminati and he
tells beast to come with them and so
what they do is they of course use
lockjaw to a teleport beasts along with
the rest of them back to Wakanda and so
what we do here is we pick up with the
Illuminati in Wakanda and what's
happening here is Doctor Strange is
planting a device in the hand of beast
and what he says is that this device or
I guess read Richard says this device
will serve two purposes
the first purpose will be to effectively
be I guess a very basic communicator it
can give them small commands send out
small commands run assemble and so on
but more so than that it will warn them
of an impending occurs n' it will warn
them of an instance when an incursion
shows up when the eight hour window
begins and so what happens here is Reed
Richards begins speaking with Black Swan
again and what he tells Black Swan is
that they have a plan and when blacks
want to ask them what their plan is he
says their plan is to use the infinity
gems to use the Infinity Gauntlet to
push the I guess the incoming earth back
into its normal reality so that they
don't have to worry about this incursion
taking place anymore
a black swan says this won't work she
says the Infinity Gauntlet exists in her
reality where at least it did and that
it will ultimately fail due to the fact
that the Iria infinity gems cannot be
used outside of their native reality and
this is a very new concept to us this is
something that we had never really
experimental with before we had never
really seen an instance where by the
Infinity Gauntlet was used or at the
very least was intended to be used in an
alternate reality and so this is
basically Jonathan Hickman telling us
that the Infinity Gauntlet exists in
their own reality and they cannot be
cannot be used outside of that native
reality and so what happens here is Reed
Richards says they're going to go
through with this plan anyway because at
the very least it's better than doing
nothing and so what happens is we pick
up four days later and four days later
is the start of another incursion and
what we learn is this incursion is
taking place in Pakistan and so is the
Illuminati gather to me the plan of
course is again explained to us that
Captain America
is going to use the Infinity Gauntlet to
push the planet Earth back and to bring
an end to this incursion and so what
happens here is Captain America during
this incursion point as simple as the
Infinity Gauntlet and uses the full
power of the gauntlet to the best of his
ability to try to push the earth back
and immediately he's successful or I
guess initially he's successful in the
sense that the earth begins to move away
but the problem here is that the rest of
the lumina the Illuminati begin to
detect some kind of a a vibration some
kind of an after effect of the Infinity
Gauntlet being used and as a result of
Captain America's actions the infinity
gems explode with the exception of the
time Jim and the time Jim simply just
vanishes and so at this point the the
entire Infinity Gauntlet is no longer of
any use and so what happens here is the
Illuminati go back to the drawing board
they regroup and they begin again
talking about the idea of using black
swans device or at the very least
creating their own device to destroy
other worlds and again Captain America
steps up and Captain America says no he
says this cannot happen they cannot use
the ID or they cannot step into the idea
of even entertaining the idea of
destroying other worlds he says the
whole reason behind them creating this
device may very well be academic but the
problem is that they over time they will
begin to I guess fall into the rationale
of saying well we should use this device
and ultimately they'll fall into the
trap of destroying other worlds in the
same way that the Black Swan had done
and so what happens here is Tony Stark
apologizes to Captain America for what
comes next and Doctor Strange uses his
powers to wipe the mind of Captain
America entirely now this is a very big
moment in the realm of the incursions
and the reason why is because if you
recall our discussion on original sin
which takes place after these few
initial comics this is the memory that
Captain America recalls when the when
the memories of The Watcher or
everything The Watcher had seen had been
shown to various people within the the
Marvel Universe
Captain America saw how his mind had
been wiped of everything that had taken
place regarding the incursions and the
New Avengers at the hands of Doctor
Strange and so what we see here after
the mind of Captain America is wiped
that the Illuminati began to go about
the process
so trying to find their own individual
ways to bring the incursians to an end
we of course see that dr. strange begins
experimenting with the idea of maybe
summoning Shue McGrath or the very least
hampering into the ideas of the blood
bible now Wang is immediately repulsed
by this idea and what he tells dr.
strange is that this requires the souls
of 40 fallen men but that it also kills
the caster but what dr. strange says is
that for the most part this is just a
necessary sacrifice but again before
they're able to get too far into their
into their investigations before they're
able to get too far into their ideas
what we find is that another incursion
is taking place and this one is taking
out taking place in New York and so what
happens is the the Illuminati band
together once again and meet at the
point of incursion and so what Reed
Richards reveals here is that his idea
alongside the idea of black panther was
to possibly use the ultimate nullifier
but the problem here is that what the
ultimate nullifier would remove the
barrier between this alternate earth and
the main earth that it wouldn't actually
end the incursion more so than that it
would also wipe out about a hundred
square miles of the immediate blast
radius and it would kill the person who
was using it and so what the Illuminati
do is they travel to the Otherworld now
once they actually arrive on this
alternate earth what they find here is
that Terrax the as it refers to himself
the enlightened is the Herald of
Galactus and he's on this earth
alongside Galactus now Galactus within
the confines of New York is actually
using his powers or using his device to
effectively destroy the world and this
is explained by Terrax what Terrax says
is that they are aware of the idea of
the incursions they know the incursions
are taking place and what they decide
here is that destroying the planet Earth
what effectively I guess destroying this
earth would effectively spare their
reality and so they're basically making
a sacrifice now initially the idea of
the Illuminati here is to fight Tareq's
and this is what they do what they
decide here is they can't simply just
allow this world to be killed they
should do what they can to end the
incursions while at the same time
sparing this planet Earth and so what
they do is they engage in conflict
directly with with Terrax now from here
we jump to the next issue of the New
Avengers and what we
fine here is that another incursion
kicks up but this time they find out the
incursion is taking place in Latveria
and so what we do here is we jump
forward yet again and what we find is
the Illuminati and Black Swan have
arrived in Latveria now within the
confines of Latveria what they find here
is that the son of dr. doom and dr. doom
himself are doing their best to hold off
this incursion but this incursion is a
little bit different and what Black Swan
tells us is that this world is a blue
world and what this means is that this
heralds the arrival of the mapmakers now
the mapmakers were initially confusing
when they first showed up in these
stories and the reason why is because
it's not clearly explained that is to
say it's not I guess totally clear by
Black Swan the way she explains it but
the way the mapmakers work is like this
the map makers travel the multiverse and
they simply have stripped worlds of
their valuable resources and what the
map makers have done is they had
previously stripped the world the
incursion point had met the world the
map makers were on with Latveria with
earth-616 and so the map makers would
jump from that alternate earth onto the
main earth-616 universe their intention
would be to I guess eliminate all
opposition and then to pull a chunk from
the alternate earth to destabilize it
and then to allow that earth to be
destroyed which would bring the
incursions to an end and it wouldn't
destroy both worlds at this point they
would go about the process of stripping
the earth-616 and then they would move
on to the next world at the next point
of incursion and so what happens here is
the Illuminati travel to the alternate
earth the earth of the mapmakers had
come from and what they realize is again
what what Black Swan told them is true
that this earth is totally devoid of all
life that the earth is totally
eliminated for the most part and so what
they do is they choose to basically
undergo the process of destroying a
world and this is a very pivotal moment
because of what this means as the
Illuminati have now crossed a line that
they can't come back from
and while Black Panther is the first
person to do it the Illuminati have
basically taken the steps in destroying
a world for the very first time with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end in the
next video we'll pick up with what
happens after this and the rammer
occasions of the Illuminati after
they've crossed this line with that
being said I will catch you guys in the
next video peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates for marvel explained and
talk to me directly